pendant le mois du commerce plusieurs
forums de l'emploi sont organisées dans
les centres commerciaux des yvelines à
l'initiative de pôle emploi comme ici à
l'espace 50 ans neuf entreprises du
territoire allant de la banque la garde
d'enfants accueil des demandeurs
d'emploi pour des rencontres informelles
c'est moins stressant et puis ils se
déplacent dans un lieu qui est un autre
lieu que pôle emploi il rencontre
quelques temps on regrette et je pense
que même s'ils sont pas recrutés il
rencontre
des gens qui leur font toujours faux pas
c'est quand même une partie de leur
expérience sur l'entretien qui donne des
conseils aussi cv lettre de motivation
entretien tous les conseils sont bons à
prendre un premier contact pour
décrocher ensuite un vrai rendez vous
c'est une première approche donc on
regarde juste le cv on voit déjà
l'expérience
on approfondira plus par la suite en
rendez vous individuels comme vous avez
déjà ya déjà des rendez-vous qui ont été
pris oui on en a deux déjà qu'ils ont
été pris et une maman également qu'ils
étaient intéressés par nos services
c'est très bien organisé
j'écoutais un souci on à pôle emploi qui
étaient là pour pouvoir nous diriger et
nous conseillaient aussi c'est super
j'ai bien tout ce forum mais il y en a
pas assez en fait
l'an dernier l'opération comptait 18
entreprises réparties sur l'espace saint
quentin et skywest ce qui avait permis
de réaliser une cinquantaine dans gauche